bonjour philippe kalfayan merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin en direct par
téléphone pour parler de cette nouvelle
crise entre entre l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan il y à de nouvelles
négociations qui reprennent aujourd'hui
après l'incursion présumé en tout cas
d'aidé azéri en territoire arménien
on a entendu les manifestants à paris
réclamé le retrait de ses troupes
qu'en est il actuellement à votre
connaissance écoutez je suis à paris ce
matin en ville mais très difficile de
parler de ce qui s'est passé dans la
nuit
mais bon ce qui en tout cas hier soir
effectivement une partie des troupes
vers la jeunesse était retirée mais il
en reste toujours quelques une incursion
comment est-ce que vous l'interprétez du
côté arménien et coûté en tout cas du
côté arménien jeu je prétendre ai pas
parlé du côté arménien en tout cas en
tant qu'observateur de de ce conflit que
je connais bien je moi je vois ça comme
un test un de la barbette gens comme
vous le savez il ya il ya un contexte
intérieur arménien et un contexte
international qui sont moins c'est
augmenter
bon le contexte intérieur c'est que un
art mini est un pays qui a été défait
militairement ans la population a été
traumatisée par cette dernière guerre et
c'est encore tout frais le toit exécutif
arménien est contesté par une grande
partie de la population ce qui fait que
ça fragilise déjà un ce pays
deuxièmement vous avez un contexte
international la création d'israël sur
palestinien est autrement plus grave et
plus dramatique
tout simplement je pense que la baisse
gentil il ne cache pas ses intentions
un de récupération de nouveaux
territoires notamment dans le sud de
l'arménie pour
créer ce fameux corridor entre entre
l'azerbaïdjan et le nakhitchevan est une
enclave de l'autre côté de l'arménie et
bien elle a fait le test
1 elle est rentrée dans le territoire
arménien elle a pris des positions
je pense qu'elle teste la réaction
internationale pour voir si elle peut
effectivement aller plus loin alors
parlons-en de la réaction internationale
vous parliez du conflit au proche orient
on voit ces c'est déjà très compliquée
la france est sollicitée on l'a vu un
pareil les manifestants pour intervenir
sur le plan diplomatique bien sûr
comment vous comment vous qualifier ce
silence relatif en tout cas des
autorités françaises écoutez l ont pas
été si silencieuse que ça parce que le
président macron assez quand même
exprimé très clairement dès le départ
sur l'intégrité territoriale de
l'arménie a demandé le retrait immédiat
des troupes barbade janelle et ils ont
aussi un an tout cas c'est ce qui est
prétendu 1 par là par le gouvernement
arménien il aurait aussi indiqué engager
une action auprès du conseil de sécurité
des nations unies pour obtenir donc une
autorisation d'aider militairement
l'arminia se défendre ou en tout cas à
repousser les troupes azerbaïdjanaise à
l'extérieur des frontières
donc c'est ce n'est pas rien maintenant
il faut quand même quand on connaît un
petit peu le système onusien et le
fonctionnement du conseil de sécurité
des nations unies les choses ne se
passent pas du tout de cette manière et
un suis très sceptique sur le fait que
le conseil de sécurité aujourd'hui
s'exprime sur ce conflit là alors
qu'aucun coup de feu n'a été tiré que ce
conseil de sécurité complètement
paralysé un parent par les tensions qui
aujourd'hui entre les grandes puissances
bon entre entre la russie et les etats
unis entre les états unis et la chine un
bon vous le voyez bien avec l'actualité
dramatique du proche orient
aucune résolution du conseil de sécurité
n'a encore été été exprimés ce qui
montre bien pu aujourd'hui le droit
international et à mains nues vient sont
totalement en panne et alors dans ce
conflit c'est vrai que là est la russie
s'activent notamment elle sera présente
pour cette reprise des discussions
aujourd'hui entre les azéri et les
arméniens
la russie peut réussir à résoudre ce
nouveau problème
écoutez elle est là elle est là en tout
cas pour ça elle sait donner ce rôle
à la fin de la guerre donc de 2020 faire
la fin de ce qu'on appelle la guerre des
44 jours ce qui est surprenant dans
cette affaire c'est que des troupes à
garda dionnet ce soit soit rentrée donc
sûr quand même sur sur trois kilomètres
dans le territoire manière sans qu' il
ait rencontré absolument aucune
résistance
deuxièmement il ya aucun coup de feu et
troisièmement on ne sont pas de
fébrilité
un yayi revan ni à moscou au contraire
il ya un ton très se rend donc est ce
que est ce que c'est une incursion
destinée à faire un peu plus pression
sur l'arménie pour tel
elle accélère le rythme des négociations
donc qui ont qui permettront de créer le
corridor donc dans le sud
c'est possible en tout état de cause la
russie qui je vous le rappelle un traité
militaire bilatérale avec l'arménie est
attendue quand même de manière très
sérieuse par les arméniens city la
russie ne bougeait pas le sentiment
antirusse est en train de s'installer en
arménie si elle skie qu'il n'est pas une
bonne chose si lesquels fayon il reste
aussi la question des prisonniers à
régler ab non seulement elle reste mais
je pense même qu'elle aurait dû être au
centre de toutes les attentions dès le
départ c'est absolument incroyable
pour le coup que l'ensemble des des
nations 1 ne soient pas mobilisés sur ce
sujet là c'est vous avez quand même 200
ha prisonnier hier à peu près le nombre
estimé on n'a même pas le nombre réel
qui sont malheureusement on peut le
supposer étaient traités dans des
conditions bon moyenne et et la moby
tenu à la communauté internationale
entre guillemets un concept qui
malheureusement est vide 1 1 ne s'est
pas mobilisée pour le retour de ces
prisonniers alors que c'est un des
points de l'accord de cessez-le-feu du 9
novembre 2000 main et donc c'est
vraiment un point qui est écrit personne
n'a bougé l'arménie a continué à
négocier avec la verve et d'or à la
russie de ce fameux corridor alors que
ce corridor a été juste mentionné comme
un projet mais ils n'étaient pas tous un
élément clé de l'accord de cessez le feu
du 9 novembre
merci beaucoup philippe kalfayan d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur arte france